if you're a fan of Hunter hunter them
for the love of marijuana please
subscribe to this channel for regular
updates straight to your YouTube feed
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
manga and more specifically welcome to
the hunter hunter Ark review where today
we will be examining the most insane
piece of story within the series being
the Chimera ant ah the Chimera ant Ark
is the six in the series and I hope
you're sitting down because I am about
to gobsmacked you with some numbers as
this Ark consists of a mighty 133 manga
chapters and 61 episodes of the 2011
anime adaptation and just to put this
into some perspective this Ark took
exactly eight years of real-world time
to publish so for any of you want peace
fans out there who may have you know not
so fond memories of experiencing the two
years straight of dressrosa
just be aware that our pain is
absolutely nothing in comparison to the
mammoth exercise of endurance that was
the Chimera ant Ark and you know what
even if you were not reading it weekly
as I certainly was not at the time this
Ark is still quite the mountain to
overcome and I'll share this right at
the beginning of this review because in
my personal experience there was a point
where I did actually stop watching it in
the 2011 anime it was around the time
when killer first encountered a cargo
and after that episode I just felt
fatigued I was incredibly sick of
watching our protagonist fight
meaningless and after meaningless and
with no clear direction of where the
story was going and I just needed to
have a break I did of course return to
the series at a later date and why how
I'm glad I did because the summit of
this arc absolutely makes all of the
setup worth it but we'll get to that
because talking about this arc is it's
actually really difficult because it's
not a simple setup we have an entire
ensemble of core characters each very
much worthy of being called a
protagonist and a depth of ideas at play
here that utterly demolished shows of
any prior arc in the series not only
that but the Chimera ant arc utterly
plunges hunter hunter into a brand new
sense of darkness and brutality with
many of the most shocking moments in the
series coming directly from this stretch
of story in one event that comes to mind
is the incredibly gruesome fate of
pockle as well as ponzu and in fact
almost any character who was unfortunate
enough to encounter an ant unprepared
but quite probably the most recognizable
moment of Darkness comes from gone
himself because he goes to some very new
and terrifying places here which I have
to say as painful as it was to
experience it with him it was such a
welcomed addition to a shounen
protagonist very very rarely will you
get to see this sort of in a dark
being suited from a character who was
theoretically set up to be your moral
compass
even though looking back on the series
that's definitely not true in God's case
but the Chimera ant ark very much
confirms the speculation of God's true
self which we had seen glimpses before
in the past but nothing like this and it
all culminates in a series defining
moment where Gahan makes an ultimate vow
throwing away everything to acquire all
of the power he would ever have simply
to defeat Peter and the key thing to
remember is that Gahan didn't defeat
Peter out of any sort of you know
necessity he does it for revenge your
and simple he reaches a point where his
despair and rage is so profound that he
is willing to give up his life to
destroy Peter for this entirely selfish
purpose it is so brilliantly human and
the tragedy that is gone will always
stand out to me as one of the greatest
highlights of hunter hunter so the
Chimera ant ark is automatically
elevated simply for containing this that
is far from the only moment that makes
this Ark though there's actually so many
that I probably won't be able to go over
everything in fact you know I definitely
won't be able to go over everything go
so I'll be talking for days but I would
also like to highlight kilowatt
immediately because his journey is the
exact opposite of God's kilowatt starts
a series in a place of darkness having
been raised as an assassin but by this
point his empathy and passion shines
brighter than anything else in this arc
and in my opinion kilowatt becomes the
emotional core of everything outside of
Kaimuki that is and it's tragic in its
own way to follow this boy who really
the only thing he wants to do in this
world is protect his best friend and to
see him have to go to such extreme
lengths in order to achieve that kill
Allah is betrayed is almost entirely
selfless and is a perfect counterbalance
to go on in this arc and the series as a
whole Plus this is also the arc that
highlights his fantastic known abilities
in God speed in particular is such a
great development for him and one of my
favorite Alec moments would be where he
implemented it against you P and this
Hawk has so many more stars on the
traditional side of the protagonist but
I do need to step back a bit now and
talk about the ants because going into
this I never would have thought that I
would be capable of feeling for such
beings I was so incredibly worried that
marijuana in particular would just turn
out to be an overpowered cell knock off
but he actually turned out to be in my
opinion one of the best written
characters in the series if not
literature as a whole and I know that
every other youtubers talked about this
to death but Mara when really is the
perfect example of how to implement an
overpowered villain at no stage during
the sock was marijuana event on the cusp
of needing to get serious so much so
that he didn't even really create any
net abilities he came naturally equipped
with one
to being or synthesis and he absorbs
some abilities from his royal guard but
this guy was never even pushed far
enough into creating his own heart -
which is just mind-boggling to think
about he was just naturally that
powerful that he got to almost
completely ignore the primary power
system of the series and yet that wasn't
even the most interesting thing about
marijuana not even close because the
main source of his character comes from
his interactions with Co McGee and the
gradual realization that there is value
beyond draw strength as well as the
constant questioning of his own
perfection because this character is the
closest thing we have to a literal God
aside from someone like nanika and yet
marijuana still could never even once
beat a blind girl in a game of gunky and
speaking of comedy it took me a while to
warm up to her in my initial run-through
of the series but by the palace invasion
and in every subsequent reviewing of the
series I appreciate her more and more
especially when it comes to thinking
about her use of Nan she is an
unconscious an end user who implements
her aura only for the purpose of winning
gungi and the condition that she is
placed on herself which is dying should
she ever lose is so incredible because
it shows how an N can be applied to
beyond the realm of combat and to such a
high degree as well that it even
surpasses the mental capabilities of a
Supreme Being and as alluded to before
Co McGee also provides an incredible
heart to the arc her presence provides a
dose of humanity at its absolute purest
the best that our species could possibly
muster which exists in stark contrast to
characters like gone or even natural who
very much explore the darker side of our
species in fact especially in regards
Metro because this arc makes it very
clear just how morally ambiguous a
seemingly joyful old man is the reality
of Metro is that he is an incredibly
cruel existence with a profound belief
in strength and even he in the end was
operating primarily for his own selfish
reasons to find a powerful opponent
which he did and I have to say that all
of the good and evil of humanity is
signed nattara versus marijuana is one
of my favorite battles that has ever
occurred in all of media in regards to
ant under specifically though it took a
huge step up by giving us a glimpse of
the pinnacle of power in the series and
one that I'm not sure we'll ever be
equaled and I think that the 2011 anime
did a marvelous job in bringing it to
life as for other primary figures are
the world god I think serve is more of
an antagonistic purpose in this arc the
marijuana does in retrospect I actually
seen marijuana as his own protagonist
working through life as best he could
consistently learning and adjusting his
instincts but the Royal Guard were a
different story altogether although most
of them do go through a similar sort of
journey the
that comes to mind immediately would of
course be you P who learns to master and
apply his rage to better serve the King
but who also comes to an understanding
with humanity at least briefly and I
guess specifically in the case of NACO
but that sort of thing was still really
great to see because you P had the
potential to be just a big dumb strong
guy but in the end he's probably at the
Royal Guard that I respect the most
with that said Peter was the one who
interested me most though especially
because they were specialists and they
came equipped with some cool abilities
and an adorable design from the very
moment they were shown with kites
severed head and while Peter was
obviously never close to the power of
that of marijuana Vito always came
equipped with the feeling that they
would use their abilities in a far more
sinister way and just stuff like the
Warped artistic depiction of them
whenever a character was thinking about
Peter made them such a uniquely scary
presence which is a fine thing to
achieve with such a cutesy design the
ultimate credit I have Peter though is
that I legitimately felt sorry for them
when they were being slaughtered by God
and after every terrible thing that
Peter had done in the series that is
pretty high praise so another fantastic
character there both was the world god I
was definitely the least on board with
even if I do appreciate the story that
is being explored through him you know
the continual doubt of the King and
plotting to do what he thinks is in the
best interest of him interesting stuff
but he was still the one I cared least
about and there are just so many
characters who deserve a huge mansion
like morale I haven't spoke about morale
yet or not knuckle and shoot each of
whom had their own series defining
moments during this mammoth arc
not to mention characters like meliora
and Cal go and well Finn but going in on
all of them would make this arc review
as long as the arc itself so I just like
to give a broad mention to the fact that
the Chimera ant ox BOTS what I believe
to be the finest cast of characters of
any arc of the series which is our
terminus because he Sokka isn't even in
it but there you go but I would like to
stop talking about characters for a bit
because the Chimera ant arc has some
intriguing changes between its anime and
manga incarnations which is important to
note the most well-known of which being
the kite situation which is more of a
change at the beginning with series but
basically in the 2011 anime the series
did not start with chitin whale Island
and we only discovered that story
through the Chimera ant Ark for me
personally as someone who watched the
anime first I found this pretty jarring
because all of a sudden there was this
character who we'd never met who was a
profound importance to gone and the
entire reason why he was on this journey
in the first place so it made an awful
lot of sense when I found out the kite
was supposed to have been in the very
first episode and the more I think about
it the more I really do believe that
this was a pretty big mistake for the
anime to have made especially when
Gaughan's entire car
Dirac is centered around his emotional
attachment kite to pull that off
you need an entire series of development
there is another situation though which
comes in the form of gyro now this is
something that confused the hell out of
me when I was watching the anime because
out of absolutely nowhere we've got this
incredibly detailed flashback of a
character who we never see and not only
that but also learning that the story
never pays off
I mean well finanical Kodu mentioned
Shiro at the end but I went on to assume
that gyro was the human who became
marijuana and that was that and I think
that the anime did quite deliberately
lead viewers to this conclusion which
was why it was an incredible shock to me
to find out that not only is gyro a
completely separate character converted
into an ant but in the manga he was
actually seen and Takashi made a very
big deal about he and gon having an
eventual meeting potentially setting up
a true ultimate form of evil in the
series and I get why the anime did it
because even in the manga this whole
Shiro situation is not paid off so why
not wrap a neat little bow around it
right here but it has led to a great
misunderstanding within the Honda Honda
community concerning gyro which is
something that I find myself constantly
battling with however within the context
of the anime as a product of its own
look it works I guess however knowing
how things are on the manga I really do
wish that they would have stuck to the
original events but to begin to
summarize my thoughts I both love and
hate this arc it has the highest of
highs and the lowest of lows in the
series everything that happens from the
palace invasion onwards I consider to be
some of the greatest storytelling ever
implemented but getting to that point is
such a difficult task and there are just
far too many random fights against
insignificant ants that blow to this arc
into oblivion I cannot even imagine what
it would have been like to spend 8 years
of my life following the series during
these events however I can't deny that
all of the effort put into it does turn
out to be more than worth it despite all
of the fatigue I felt when going through
this arc it reached a point of becoming
one of the most compelling and special
pieces of media that I've ever consumed
and it's a huge contributing factor to
why I decided to heavily feature hunt
hunter on this channel so I will always
remember it incredibly fondly and I feel
like most of the people who were able to
survive this are very much in the same
boat so well done Takashi for telling
this great long form story and
completely redefining hunter hunter in
the process and that pretty much does it
for this review of the Chimera ant op if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general and
please do consider donating to the new
world review patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and to pay
Tron isn't quite your style please do
leave this video a like share or
subscribe because it also helps for this
channel and incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at anytime
then please do head over to my desk
world server where a wide array of
January takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on the Chimera ant Ark this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]